مساء الخير التاريخ ليس مجرد كتاب مليء
بالقصص المسليه والجغرافيا ليست مجرد اطلس
ملون الجينات الوراثيه للانسان بتحدد الى
حد كبير جدا شخصيته وحاضره ومستقبله
وسلوكه مع الناس وكذلك المكون الجغرافي
والتاريخي لاي بلد من البلدان بيحدد قدرته
على انه يتبنى نظام ديمقراطي ولا استبدادي
قدرته على تحقيق مستوى من التنميه
الاقتصاديه بقدر قد ايه وحتى كثير من
الحروب للدول بتاخدها بشكل انفيت ابل يعني
حتمي لان الجغرافيا بتفرض عليها ان تخوض
هذه الروض الامثله كثيره جدا ابرز مثل في
الوقت
الحالي خارج المنطقه العربيه هي روسيا
روسيا خاضت معظم حروبها معظم حروبها خلال
المئات السنين الماضيه بحث بث عن منافذ
مياه بلد ضخم وليس عنده منافذ مياه بيبحث
دائما عن منافذ مياه وصولا الى ما يسمى
بالمياه الدافئه والبحر المتوسط فطوال
الوقت بيحارب تركيا دخلت الحرب العالميه
الاولى بحثا عن
منافذ وبضايق
للمياه وموانئ بحريه فطول الوقت هي بتخوض
هذه الحروب بحثا عن هذه المشكله
الجغرافيه علاقه الصين بلد زي التبات او
منطقه التبات اللي بتحاول تستقل عن اقليم
التبات اللي بيحاول يستقل مشكلتها
الاساسيه بالنسبه للصين انها ارض سهله
منبسطه جدا وبالتالي عدم السيطره عليها
يعني قدره الهند على انها تكتح وتهدد
امنها بمنتهى البساطه الامثله كثيره كثيره
جدا بتحدد ليه جغرافيا بلد من البلدان
مضطر ان يتصرف على هذا النحو في المنطقه
العربيه وبعد
شهدت عدد من الدول العربيه موجات مما سمي
بثورات الربيع العربي دول منه نجت باقل
قدر ممكن من التغيير والضرر ودول اخرى
انهارت وتكاد تخرج من الخريطه نهائيا
الدول اللي نجت لما نجي لازم علشان نفهم
الفرق ويه السبب لازم نبص على الجغرافيا
ونبص على
التاريخ الدول اللي نجت زي مصر وزي تونس
وهما الدوله يعني اللي بداوا بال بالثورات
دول التغيير فيها محدود جدا نظام مكان
نظام اذا كان نظام اكثر ديمقراطيه او اكثر
ديكتاتوريه نظام برلماني نظام رئاسي تغير
في القوى السياسيه تيجي قوى اسلاميه تخرج
قوى علمانيه لكن في النهايه لم تنهار لا
تونس ولا مصر فيما نهارت سوريا وليبيا
واليمن وطبعا العراق ما كانش محتاج انه
يتعرض الى ثورات الربيع العربي لانه كان
منهار بالفعل لما نيجي ندقق في الخلفيه
التاريخيه هنلاقي بلد زي مصر وتونس حدودهم
الجغرافيه منذ قديم الزمن ليست محل خلاف
وليس ومش مرسومه بالم كثيف او ثقيل الم
رصاص ثقيل عمله مستعمر يعني الحدود دي
موجوده طبيعيه والخلافات الحدوديه في بلد
زي مصر او تونس محدوده في بلد زي مصر مثلا
اكثر الخلافات اللي بتطرح ايه واحه
الجغبوب
في الناحيه الغربيه هي مصريه ولا ليبيه في
الجنوب هل حلايب وشلاتين مصريه ولا
سودانيه هيي خلافات محدوده هل طيران
وصنافير
الجزيرتين الصغيرتين مصريتان ام سعوديتان
كل دي محدوده جدا يعني تاثيرها محدود على
العكس بلد زي اليمن على العكس بلد زي
ليبيا على العكس سوريا
الجغرافيا بتقول ان هذه الدول الثلاث لم
تكن دولا بالحدود القائمه قبل 2011 منذ
قديم الازل لا ابدا كانت اقاليم وولايات
ودويلات
جمعها منطق واحد هي مناطق نفوذ للمستعمر
الاساسي الامبراطوريات التي كانت تحكم
المنطقه هذه الامبراطوريات جمعت هذه
المناطق ليس بحكم ان هي جمع منطقي
وا يعني مبني على اساس ديموغرافي سكاني
وتاريخي وانسجام ما بين الطوائف المختلفه
ولكن على اساس مناطق النفوس وكانت ممكن
جدا جزء من التركيا يبقى مع سوريا وجزء من
سوريا يبقى في العراق وجزء من ده كان
بالفعل كده وجزء من الاردن يكون تبع سوريا
المساله تم تقسيمها تقسيما فجا وفقا لرؤيه
ومصالح الدولتين الكبار المستعمرين كانت
انجلترا وفرنسا الدول دي استقرت وظلت
لفتره طويله من بعد الحرب العالميه الاولى
وبعضها من بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بحكم لانه الجغرافيا بتقول لا
الجغرافيا ترفض هذا الجمع طيب النتيجه
انه عفوا ان هذه الدول كانت موجوده تحت
حكم امبراطوريات قويه الامبراطوريه
العثمانيه سلمتها الى الامبراطوريات
الغربيه الجديده البريطانيه والفرنسيه
ولما تراجعت هذه الامبراطوريات بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه تسلم الرايه مجموعه اللي
بيسموهم في يعني يسموهم سترونج مان سترونج
مان ترجمتها مش الرجال الاقوياء اللي هم
المستبدين وال دكتورز زي قذافي في ليبيا
زي الصدام حسين في العراق زي حافظ ثم بشار
الاسد في سوريا وزي علي عبد الله صالح في
اليمن وقبلهم مجموعه من الانظمه ايضا
القمعيه طيب تحت الامبراطوريات كانت الدول
دي تعيش تحت القوه العسكريه والاراده
السياسيه لدول كبيره ولما خرجت عاشت هذه
الدول بمكونات متنافره ومتنا احره تحت
اراده حاكم قوي جدا وظف كل ادوات القمع
والمسايرات نفره كما كان الوضع في العراق
على سبيل المثال ما انهارت هذه الانظمه
مؤخرا
سواء في 2003 بعد سقوط بعد غزو الامريكان
للعراق او بعد ثورات الربيع العربي اللي
ادت
الى انتهاء قذافي وحكم علي عبد الله صالح
وبتعرض حكم بشار الاسد الى ضغوط عنيفه جدا
عادت هذه الدول مره اخرى الى ما كانت عليه
قبل اتفاقيات سيكسبيكو وغيرها من
المعاهدات اللي ادت الى قيام هذه الدول
عكس الدول اللي كانت بتتمتع بحدود قويه
طبيعيه مساله مش بس مجرد مصر وتونس المغرب
كذلك الى حد كبير ايران وده واحد من اهم
مصادر قوتها انه ايا كان عدد اعدائها هي
دوله موجوده منذ قدم التاريخ في حدودها
يبقى في خلاف حدودي على الجزر الاماراتيه
على منطقه هنا منطقه هناك لكنها منطقه لم
يرسمها يد مستعمر النتيجه انه بسبب هذا
الميراث التاريخي الثقيل وبسبب الصعوبات
الجغرافيه اللي تتعلق
بالحدود المرسومه هذه الدول تعاني بشده
بعد سقوط انظمتها
الدكتاتوريه كلامي لا يعني ان انا اسي على
انظمه ديكتاتوريه بقول انه هذه الانظمه
قدامك ان تحدد خياراتك اذا كنت بتتكلم على
عراق او سوريا كمكون ظل موجود من اواخر
من بعد الحرب العالميه الاولى
ولغايه السنوات قليله ماضيه يبقى انت
الحقيقه بتتكلم انه اهم ميزه لهذه الانظمه
الدكتاتوريه انها ابقت على هذه الدول
انتاكت بدون ان
تمس اما اذا كنت بتتكلم على حريات
وديمقراطي و فطبعا نصيب او
الاهتمام اللي بذلوا هذه الانظمه للملفات
دي يكاد يك يكون محدود جدا كان الامل
الوحيد وربما تكون كانت فرصه ضائعه عشان
الدول دي تحظى بالخطوه رقم اثنين انها
تخرج من المعادله الصعبه دي اللي تعرضت
لها يوغسلافيا بالمناسبه في اوروبا ودول
اخرى يعني انه كانت هذه الانظمه
الديكتاتوريه تخرج من مرحله الى مرحله من
مرحله الابقاء على الدول دي بكل مكوناتها
المتنافره الى مرحله اخرى انه تعمل عمليه
رخاء ووئام ومشاركه في السلطه تشجع كل هذه
المكونات على البقاء رغبه منها وليس رغما
عنها زي مثل ليس متطابق ولكن مشابه يعني
في عندنا المانيا الشرقيه بعد سقوط
الاتحاد السوفيتي ساعه ان هم ينسجم ليه
ينسجم مع ان هم كان ممكن جغرافيا يكونوا
يعني ماشيه الامور ويكون كل دوله مستقله
لوحدها لكن اللي بيحصل انه مصلحه المانيا
الغربيه ان هي كانت تسعى دوله غنيه وتسعى
الى وجود ايدي عامله فيما
كانت المانيا الشرقيه دوله فقيره وتسعى
الى مزيد من الرفاهيه المثل مختلف لكن
بقول ان المصالح ممكن تجمع تجمع الدول حتى
وان كانوا انفصلوا بالفعل الولايات
المتحده 50 ولايه كل منها بيتسابق على
البكاء البقاء داخل الاتحاد الفيدرالي
لانه بيعتقد ان مصلحته وليس رغما عنه
البقاء في هذا الاتحاد الفيدرالي مره اخرى
هذه امثله مختلفه كان ممكن بعض هذه الدول
لو كان نجح حكامها التاريخيين زي صدام او
زي حافظ او زي علي عبد الله صالح او
القذافي في انه ياخدوا هذه الخطوه ربما
كان الوضع مختلف هؤلاء الحكام لم ياخذوا
هذه الخطوه لاسباب كثيره ربما تكون
برغبتهم ربما تكون رغما عنهم مساله تحتاج
بحث لكن المؤكد ان الفرصه ضاعت وف هذه
الدول في العوده مره اخرى للحمه واحده
ودوله واحده في منتهى الصعوبه بسبب كوابيس
التاريخ وانتقام الجغرافيا اشكركم والى
لقاء اخر ان شاء الله